I'm getting sick and tired of you
pranking me about this booger in my nose
she popped his mouth wide open shot of
his blouse upside the head twice
and he threatens to kick her out of the
car you thought I was joking
this is a clear case of when you're
playing with your partner and you think
they're playing with you
but they're not no I feel like I'm being
punished oh things got rough for these
two we're gonna talk about it plus
jabri's mom tells meona she needs to
wear clothes that are not as revealing
in the house especially around her
husband in the house and and Brian's
around and that kind of thing I'm just
wondering if you might be willing to
wear some that you already have that's a
little bit more modest I have mixed
feelings about this conversation and I
can't wait to hear your thoughts let's
get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissia
I'm not gonna lie I'm with some of you
I'm starting to miss the Gino and
Jasmine of it all so take off
those are not and Angela and Michael
listen I should have left you when I
went over there and your penis wasn't
what you said it was you alive from the
beginning Michael I need some spice in
my 90-day life yes
Wild Ones this week's episode of 90 day
was good though let's get into Bilal and
shaida's fight starting from the top
today is the first Friday that shite is
here with me so I'm taking shaida
tanjuma Bilal and shaida are headed to a
worship service and we pray and it's
very similar to what a Christian may do
on Sunday when they go to church
and shaida is extremely nervous because
on top of meeting his spiritual family
she's also meeting his ex-wife who's the
mother of his kids my nerves are on high
because it's important for us to get
along
if she doesn't approve of me that
negatively affects my relationship with
below because her negativity will rub
off on your children and they would
share it on me and I don't I'm not
looking for toxic or problems right now
in the car Shai expresses how anxious
she is to below but she starts to feel
like he isn't really hearing her because
instead of just acknowledging how she
feels he starts to do what a lot of us
do when we try to make someone feel
better which is we make it about us
everything you're feeling
I've been through the same stuff you
know remember I met your people before
you met my people and you have to
understand you came as a visitor I am
coming here with the possibility of
staying here forever and making my life
with you so my situation is different
you cannot take away how I feel
the point I was making was is that I can
relate to you I was trying to connect
with you when talking to the cameras
Shadow reveals that Bilal thinks she's
overreacting and he's always lecturing
her I'm not looking for you to be my dad
I'm looking for you to be my supportive
fiancee and speak to me like your fiance
once she reminds Bilal to just respect
how she feels he says okay but then this
little prankster tell shot she has a
booger in her nose
and that joke is what leads to the fight
you just might
want to get that booger out of your nose
before you read it I don't have no big
on my mind it's green and brownish oh
whatever and if you have something stuck
in your teeth look like you got a hair
on it this is clearly a joke below pulls
often because shaida didn't even bother
to look I'm getting sick and tired if
you prompted me about this booger in my
nose I hate this type of joke that's an
American thing wait let's take a moment
to look at bilal's face when Shada hit
him upside the head that was the type of
Pop you give a child I guess that shadow
was playing but I know a lot of grown
men who would not let that fly
especially when there are cameras in the
car filming you for a national
television show
I don't know where you come from
but the environment I come from
we keep our hands to ourselves so I
can't do that so so what I'm gonna tell
you is
stop you're gonna try to get a wreck
shadow goes on to tell below that people
in her country are touchy-feely but he
could care less
it's disrespectful where I come from to
be honest I've been in a position
similar to Shadows before where I was in
a playful mood it turns out the person I
was playing with wasn't but I didn't
pick that up until it was too late and
then I was like oh
now I have to deal with you being mad at
me
can you just let this go it happens
Keep Your Hands to Yourself
watch your tone because I can literally
pull over right now and you'll be taking
an Uber for the rest of the ride home
and then when you come to my country
I did not say I did not say did I just
put your hands on me yeah but it's not
just in a serious way yeah no I'm gonna
give you a serious hit
now shut up
you pushed it below starts to pull over
on the side of the highway and he calls
shaida aggressive and says she's making
him see her in a different light and
while shaida says she meant it as a joke
Bilal doesn't see anything funny here
you have to be alive not just stuff I
decided they were like this yeah this is
the highway because I give you a little
top yeah you see she didn't do it again
I'm thinking you're actually a violent
person
and that's what I'm not trying to be
with at this point Bilal gets back on
the road and has to pick up his kids
but Shada is confused by his reaction
and she brings up his Infamous prank
when he made her say in his old house
during her first night in America I
don't understand like Bella put me
through this horrible prank having me
spend the night at his whole house I
would think that he would have had a
much lighter sense of humor when it
comes to me giving him a little tap in
the head but apparently like he's not
playful when it comes to him
oh what do y'all think do you think
Bilal overreacted or do you think shot
pushed it or is it both I think Shy
pushed it when someone tells you to stop
you should stop that's rule number one
period but I also think it was a bit
dramatic for below to pull over the car
on the highway
knowing he was not about to make her get
out
they get to the Islamic Center and Bilal
basically leaves shy on her own
I feel alone
he is preaching his relatives his
friends and his community
and I'm by myself
he's not trying to make me feel better
he is upset he's skipping distance but
when it was time for her to meet below's
ex-wife things actually went well which
doesn't really surprise me his ex-wife
seems cool so shahida this is shaida
nice to meet you and this is the Lady of
the house
she's so pretty
yeah all right
after the service below dropped shy back
off at home and takes his kids to
practice
when he returns to the house shy is
dressed up and ready for their scheduled
date night but he tells her he is not in
the mood still kind of taken away for
like what happened in the car Bilal
explains that he was upset that she
repeatedly touched him when he asked her
not to and shy responds by saying she
was playing once again I'm the biggest
jokester that it is so I get all that
fun and humor and all that but then
there's also a time when you do
something and somebody's like you know
what you overstepped your boundaries
it's like
my bad I didn't mean it that way but
then for you was just like you know
just kept you kept you kept I feel like
Bilal he tends to get hurt so easily
where I come from we say things we
offend each other and we move on
shatta says she thinks cultural
differences are getting in the way here
and she even tears up when she explains
to below how isolated he made her feel
at the worship service
I mean obviously I don't want you to cry
but it was it was pretty hurtful to me
but she goes on to assure him that she
will not put her hands on him again now
that she knows it's seriously upset him
I'm very very sorry
and I will not do it again and he
accepts her apology but after this
entire incident it's clear to him that
they are not ready for marriage
right now we are not ready to walk down
at all
no I feel like I'm being punished
because you can't celebrate nights
I didn't say how to cancel today late I
said I didn't really feel like going
because we needed to talk about this I
mean
everything was just the day did not go
the way that I hope it to go
oh The Growing Pains of being in a
relationship you have to learn where
your partner's boundaries are some
people are okay with play hitting which
if you ask me that can get real sticky
and then you have others who are just
flat out against it also you teach
people how to treat you so although I
think below was being a bit stubborn for
holding on to it for so long
like Shadow said
she'll never do it again
when I spoke to Bilal and Shadow last
month I asked him about what was going
through his head when he threatened to
kick her out of the car and here's what
he had to say one of the things that she
always will talk about that she's she's
attracted to
um someone who doesn't pacify her you
know or someone who has a backbone you
always say that like you need to give
back more so it's kind of like I'm in a
catch 22. you know I I try to appease
her and at the same time she wants the
backbone so and anytime I'm like okay if
I have a different opinion than her and
I'm trying to stand up have this
backbone and then it's kind of like the
Trini yeah force of come at you and it's
like dude like what's the deal we need
to get to a compromise instead of me
just always kneeling and bowing down to
you oh speaking of compromise let's get
into jabri's mom Mahala and miona
hopefully they can find some common
ground when it comes to how miona
dresses I've been in the US for a few
weeks and it's definitely not as
comfortable as I wish to live in this
house debris is off working on music and
miona is at the house still adjusting to
life in South Dakota and living with
jabri's parents I feel like Drew Brees
parents are nice people but also strict
a little bit Mahala comes downstairs and
offers to help me on and do her laundry
they get in the laundry room and miona
picks up one of her crop tops what is
that
like for your hair
no that's that that's a top
oh
I was like this
okay
um you don't like it
I think it it's I think it's little
this is when jabri's mom takes an
opportunity to bring up the way miona
dresses which has been a concern of hers
before miona even made it to America
it's just interesting to see some of the
things because like when jabri was first
showing me your like social media and
that kind of stuff before you came I was
a little bit nervous about how you might
adjust to Rapid City because not a lot
of people kind of wear
shirts that little here
let me go ahead and tell you why I have
mixed feelings before we get into the
rest jabri's mom is a therapist which
means she should know how our minds work
and for the most part she should be a
great communicator but I feel like this
conversation she had with miona
came off judgmental and I'm sure this
was not her intention but it also seemed
as if she was trying to shame miona into
changing you seem like really
intelligent
and I just worry that sometimes wearing
a shirt like what you just showed me
can take away from that can be a
distraction
I understand but I want to express
myself how I want and I want to learn to
be comfortable in my body that on top of
her bringing up the residents of South
Dakota I was a little bit nervous about
how you might adjust to Rapid City
because not a lot of people kind of wear
shirts that little here
in my opinion isn't the best approach it
doesn't come off as if she's trying to
help this 23 year old girl see things
from A New Perspective it just sounds
like slight shade also personally I just
don't believe in telling people to tone
down who they are to fit in I mean look
at her son he lives in South Dakota and
I know he's a unicorn there no one else
looks or dresses like him this is who I
am and I am Goofy and I am wild and I
got a lot of energy what you gonna do
about it now on the other hand this is
the other side of my mixed feelings I
can only imagine how difficult of a
conversation this is to have with your
son's fiance in the first place so it's
not going to be perfect and also to be
woman enough to say what Mahala says
next to miona about her husband Brian
it's something you can't help but
respect and I don't want to judge you
but I do want to ask that like when you
and jabri are out doing your thing you
can wear whatever you wear obviously
um in the house and and Ryan's around
and that kind of thing I'm just
wondering if you might be willing to not
change like your clothes but just wear
some that you already have that's a
little bit more modest a little bit more
covering
foreign
[Music]
at the end of the day it's all about
respect miona says this conversation
doesn't feel great and it makes her feel
like a child but after all it's mahala's
house
if miona chooses not to adjust the way
that she dresses in our home to me that
is a sign of a deeper issue of
disrespect
why do her needs Trump everybody else's
needs
true
and of course you know miona tells jabri
about this conversation
so I was putting some stuff in the
laundry and she was like what kind of
top is that why is she doing all that
she's like I don't want you walking
around the house in that
and then she would mention that you
don't want me like walking in front of
Brian like that
that was really weird she's taking it
too far
jabri approaches his mother about it
honestly I'm just gonna get straight to
it I'm I'm pissed off
because this is not how I expected this
to go and miona is not feeling
comfortable as the conversation goes on
in my opinion jabri's Mom starts to play
a little bit more innocent than she
really was in her conversation with
miona she's feeling like they're trying
to change her into somebody and I don't
understand if you're just trying to be
like overproductive Mom but I'm not 15
years old anymore
so I I don't know what you're talking
about
when I was talking with miona
she didn't seem this upset
was that not real
of course she's not gonna go off on you
she's living in your house and you're
about to be her mother-in-law it was
clear as day that miona didn't feel like
that was a safe space
but
okay I'm getting married I got 90 days I
got a lot of pressure she don't she only
get married and God knows where and
that's stresses me out so Jerry what are
you really upset about because I think
it's sounding more like you're upset
about how you and miona are doing right
now this conversation became less about
his mom asking miona to dress
differently and more about the pressure
miona is putting on debris to leave his
parents house and live the life of her
dreams which is having this beautiful
wedding on the beach and living in La
the pressure debris is feeling is what
has his mom concerned that he's moving
too fast with miona and he's headed for
a brick wall you're not gonna always be
there to pick me up no I know myself
the one who's supposed to be there with
you to be there when you pick yourself
up then I gotta know that she can do it
or what do the work
that she's not gonna sit there and and
and expect everybody else to do the work
for her because she's pretty or shows
her breasts wow debris
if you think I'll make a mistake which
is how I'm taking this let me make it
I know that's hard for a mom to hear
well next week miona meets another
special woman in jabri's life the
coolest grandma in the world I really
hope my grandma likes me on them
so what do you think of um Rapid City so
far I want to move from here definitely
but it's a good place to save money so
don't speak for both of us
[Music]
will miona get her way
we'll see all right 90 day fans fam make
sure you stick with ET because we are
covering it all I will see you next time
[Music]